Jeff the Nordic leaders plan to focus
mostly on increasing cooperation in the
Arctic and fighting climate change but
their agenda took a detour okay leaders
of Nordic Nations gathered for the final
day of talks but their discussions
revolved around someone who was not in
the room Russian President Vladimir
Putin Iceland invited prime minister
Justin Trudeau as a special guest this
is obviously a very
challenging internal situation in Russia
this is the head of a significant
military paramilitary organization in
the Wagner group you know taking some
bold actions challenging the regime we
discussed the events of last Saturday in
Russia which shows really how on
countries that neighbor Russia the risk
is even more real we have to be ready
and I'm happy that we are well prepared
at this moment the West is well prepared
NATO is well prepared but we have to be
ready
[Applause]
Finland recently joined NATO the
organization's Secretary General called
the short-lived rebellion in Russia
another sign Putin's war in Ukraine was
a mistake
weakness of the of the Russian regime
and it also demonstrates how how
difficult and dangerous it is for
President Putin to be reliant on
Mercenaries Sweden is pushing to become
a NATO member ahead of next month's
Summit in Lithuania and we need to make
sure that he gets you
Trudeau met with
you were actually the first country
right ratifying Sweden but turkey is
standing in the way the Turkish
president is blocking its entry into the
alliance accusing Sweden of harboring
terrorists the Turks and swedes will
have a sit down in Brussels before the
NATO Summit prime minister Justin
Trudeau says he will continue to support
Sweden's bid for membership as Western
leaders try to respond to an
increasingly unpredictable Russia Jeff
three isri and Reykjavik Iceland thanks
to Ria